SAAD ALI: All right.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Saad Ali.
We're here at KubeCon
Barcelona, and with me today
is Aaron Crickenberger.
He has a lot of
hats that he wears.
He's a Google engineer.
He is on the Kubernetes
Steering Committee,
and he's been involved with a
lot about Kubernetes releases.
Aaron, can you talk a little
bit about the releases
that you've been
involved with and how
they've evolved over time?
AARON CRICKENBERGER: Sure.
I've been involved with
Kubernetes releases
since Kubernetes was version
1.4, and at the beginning,
it was just sort of
a select few Google
people who were hardcore enough
and had the right privileges
to make this happen.
Over time, I saw the release
process gradually hand
over more and more
control to the community.
I started out writing
release notes,
you know, attempting to
sort of reverse engineer
a coherent narrative out of this
chaotic, open-source process.
And over time, grew into other
roles such as issue triage--
keeping track of
how do we actually
know what's happening
within the release,
and make sure the right
things are being focused on--
to CI signal-- you
know, how do we
make sure that a given
Kubernetes release is actually
healthy and ready to
ship out the door?
And that sort of culminated
in me acting as a release
lead for Kubernetes 1.14, which
I was especially proud of,
because it was the release with
the most stable enhancements
out of any Kubernetes release.
And it was also
the first release
where the community agreed to
use the Kubernetes Enhancement
Proposal process,
or KEP process,
to ship features,
which to me, was really
a sign of just how mature
the release process has come.
And while I was
doing this, I was
assisted by a team
of over 40 people
serving in 13 different
roles to ensure
that mostly all I had to
do was watch everything
proceed super smoothly.
And it culminated in me getting
to create this cat T-shirt here
where every release
team member gets
a piece of swag as sort of
the honorary badge of running
the release for three months.
And my piece of swag
was cat-ernetes,
you know, three cats looking
up at the Kubernetes logo
sort of like three wolf moon.
SAAD ALI: Very cool.
And so you mentioned how this
process has become better
and is more community owned.
There's a lot of
other work going on
to improve the
Kubernetes community.
Can you talk about some of that?
AARON CRICKENBERGER: Sure.
Back when Kubernetes
first started,
we weren't even sort
of very organized
in terms of what we were doing.
It was just some
very driven companies
and contributors
trying to push code out
as quickly as possible.
And we gradually
realized that we
needed to get like-minded
people together
to talk about different
areas that they were
interested in coordinating on.
So I used to work with a
guy named Bob Weiss who--
I worked with him to
co-found SIG Scalability,
the first special
interest group.
I then worked to co-found
the second special interest
group called SIG Testing, all
about the testing of Kubernetes
to make sure that worked well.
Today, we now have over 31
special interest groups,
and we've also
created working groups
that are collaborations between
special interest groups.
So we've really sort
of federated out
and empowered the
decision-making process
for this open-source community.
And at the same
time, we've been very
intentional about focusing
on inclusion and diversity
through this whole process,
taking a look at how we engage
with our community members
and with our contributors,
and looking at the
examples that we
set to ensure that we're acting
in as inclusive a manner as
possible, sort of setting
up work and describing roles
to make it easier to
onboard people who are maybe
intimidated or overwhelmed
by contributing
to a project that is as large
and fast moving as Kubernetes.
So I've really been happy
to see that sort of pay off.
And I think that attitude
has been reflected
in the KubeCon conference that
sort of hangs around Kubernetes
where there's these diversity
scholarships that happen
each year, and you sort of see
this nice exponential growth
curve.
I thought it was really neat to
hear the story today of Nikita
[INAUDIBLE],, who described her
journey from sort of college
student to owner of
very fundamental parts
of the Kubernetes
code base today.
And, you know, she got
there by showing up
to one of these special
interest groups,
feeling like she was heard.
She found a mentor who was
willing to help her out,
and she managed to get
to her first KubeCon
by way of a
diversity scholarship
to really experience
all the wonderful stuff
that this community
has to offer.
I also thought another
really great thing
I saw in this KubeCon was
sort of more of a focus
on mental health,
realizing that because this
is such a large and
overwhelming open-source
project that some people
can maybe burn out or maybe
feel a little uncertain
of themselves.
And so I actually tweeted
about this at the last KubeCon.
It was super exhausting
to me, actually.
I think I gave six
talks throughout a week.
It was a lot.
And I said, hey,
I think we really
need to talk about burnout.
And I heard back
from over 200 people
sharing with me
their experiences
and what they were
up to and what
they were coming up against.
And some of the
constructive criticism
that they had to offer both
me as an individual, as well
as the conference
organizers, to improve this.
And today, I just came out
of a mental health talk
to hear how companies
who contribute
to all of the projects here
that are hosted by the CNCF
are taking mental
health very seriously.
SAAD ALI: That's awesome.
So it sounds like there's a lot
of really great work going on
to make the Kubernetes community
not only more diverse, but also
more sustainable.
Make sure that we can continue
to do all the great work
that we've been doing.
So thank you for all
your work on that.
Last question-- what
are you looking forward
to here at KubeCon this year?
AARON CRICKENBERGER: Well,
like I said earlier, I
think the thing I was
most looking forward to
was getting to see that mental
health talk and hear the--
like, I stayed after
the talk and heard
so many community members
ask questions and follow-up
questions afterwards.
That was my second talk was just
hearing everybody else engage
and following that conversation.
I'm also, selfishly,
really interested
in my panel at the end of
Thursday to talk about burnout
and how we can
leverage this community
to set better norms for self
care and things like that.
SAAD ALI: Cool.
Well, thank you so much
for your time, Aaron.
AARON CRICKENBERGER: Cool.
Thanks a lot, Saad.
Great to be here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]